ciel ma mère alors marcel la jeunesse
bonsoir silva jean pierre armand bonsoir
bonsoir
alors marseille ça vous arrive souvent
de doubler des films porno comme ça de
temps à autre mais ça n'est pas une
spécialisation de les doubler qui par
exemple dans la vie comme ça on la vit
non ça j'ai pas j'ai pas fait que du
port new wave là dieu merci d'ailleurs
j'ai doublé pas mal de films et ce qui
paraît aberrant d'ailleurs c'est que
j'ai doublé les premiers promeniez
premier film des mariés non non c'est
vous la voix française de maman au
départ quand elle était venue de boxe
repas ouais
et puis après quand elle est passée
vedette fox c'était une autre camarade
qui était remarquable dessus des vertus
je double et audrey hepburn est alors
maintenant ils y ont pris de l'âge quand
même allons les derniers que je vous
blessez madame chez les welters je ne
suis tout à fait c'est ça qui est
amusant dans cette profession d hier
jean fait souvent mais je ne parle
jamais ça ou non pas très tôt par une
[ __ ] temps
elle est beaucoup et puis le marché je
prends c'est râlant fait ça très bien
on essaie de travailler mes posts
exemple c'est en fait le bruit la série
ça là on travaille à l'image d'un style
n'est pas toujours drôle cette grand
mère je suis grand neil sammonds
petits-enfants fait ripaille le porno je
sais pas le doublé à jouer le classement
général mais pas le pendule de toute
façon je dis bonjour et j'ai mes
petits-enfants détiennent cette voie là
mais le film s'appelle remplissez moi je
trouve ce titre assez tangible sur ses
senneurs bluetooth non mais je suis là
et particulière c'est mon nom mais ce
serait fastidieux de faire ça tout ça
oui un rôle à la bombe
moi j'ai pensé que j'ai ça tout le temps
long vous avez vraiment l'air de savoir
bien de faire et c'est un métier j'ai pu
dire si vous êtes avec un homme dans un
livre allait faire les bruits le type va
croire que vous lui donnez beaucoup de
plaisir finalement formation
professionnelle j'avais pas pensé à vous
parce que finalement le type croire que
vous devez beaucoup plaisir alors qu'il
vous fait aucun effet finalement vous
êtes capable de faire tous les bruits de
la jouissance du plaisir on est
l'invention quand même les femmes
n'avaient rien à vous alors jean-pierre
toi tu as fait cheveux courts et a fait
une porno toi 2003 2004 2003 2004
ces foules et mme rice en 17 ans en 17
ans
alors là où j'ai toujours posé une
question je vous dirais bon c'est vrai
qu'à les types qui font le haut et
d'autres qui font le bao oui le problème
il essaime c'est que souvent les
metteurs en scène où les producteurs
engagent des comédiens way qui sont
débutants donc ce n'est pas évident
qu'ils puissent fonctionner à voir
l'érection facilement alors ils font ce
qu'on appelle la comédie ouais ils font
le début de l'érotisme soft qu'on
appelle et puis ensuite quand arrive le
garde vous comédiens se retire ou
pendant que la caméra montre sur les
visages ensuite arrive le buzzer
professionnel je m'excuse mais je vous
en prie qui lui fait la pénétration
ouais puis alors que ça se passe on
continue et on continue on s'envoie pas
que le jeune comédien de 20 ans qui est
beau comme un prince qui s'accomplit la
caméra ensuite romain sur le visage
pendant ce temps le vieux de la vieille
donc je fais partie ça veut dire
il accueillera rodez sein de la
pollution euro 6 anciens alors
maintenant deuxième question c'est quoi
le secret ja comment tu peux demander
comme ça sur sur commande non plus utile
puisque je vais te dire que là il ya
plein de téléspectateurs que savoir à
mon niveau déjà il ya l'expérience
ouais il s'étend déjà tu sais te mettre
en condition c'est facile je m'absente
au moins 30 secondes y en a trop besoin
de deux heures ouais
puis derrière moi il n'y arrive jamais
puis déjà connu ce qu'ils beaucoup de
débutants lorsque des gens elle présence
une personnalité un comédien connu ou 1
en vue de la vieille qui a 15 ans le
métier que dix ans de déclin qui sait
qu'il doit travailler avec cette
personne alors déjà le garçon 1
il peut pas tirer alors puis en plus de
ça bon moi j'ai une technique c'était ma
technique est simple c'est bon je pense
à rien ouais que là que mes partenaires
me plaise ou pas je travaillerai
normalement que je ne pense pas que je
me plaise ou pas ce n'est pas mon
problème toute façon mais les femmes
avec une fille tu trouve plutôt match
oui je m'en prit j'arrive quand même à
oui parce que je suis payé une aubaine
toit pour les femmes non ça c'est ma vie
professionnelle et ma vie privée mais en
parler après allez donc en plus derrière
moi j'ai quand même bien temps de yoga
donc non non il ya cependant que c'est
pas un problème concentration c'est un
problème de mental j'ai pu me concentrer
pour faire de ces normes
je suis moi même à la limite mais est ce
que comme ans était venu je dirai ce que
le départ comment tu as tu as découverte
20 dhombres pour ce genre de film
comment ça s'est passé non ça s'est
passé chez moi dans le midi d'où je suis
originaire au capteur plus grand centre
naturiste de vote
ouais et j'étais très jeune à l'époque
un jour metteur en scène américain rich
meyer ou m'a demandé de faire des films
pour nous comment tu l'a rencontrée
aspects à la plage ah bon il a vu tout
nu dans huit ou dix mâles il a vu que
c'était particulièrement bien équipé
voilà alors il m'a dit il m'a dit est ce
que tu veux faire des films pour nous
alors moi en à yves manguy lit dans ma
campagne 2010 j'ai dit qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire
evans il faut baiser était payé un chili
s'est dit finalement c'est un bon job
c'est ce week-end que la méphédrone le
fc samer visiteurs par jour en usine
nécessaire si je suis plein et j'appuie
sur l'amour et des créatures d'accord
pour bonheur pour un grand bonheur pour
moi cela fonctionnait au premier coup
lorsque s'agit pas là des années ce
qu'on utilise ailleurs n'existait pas en
france
cette tournée à l'étranger la barre oui
et lorsque le hard est arrivé en france
pour moi c'est une facilité parce que
j'avais déjà deux trois ans de métier
derrière depuis six états les 5 6 me le
fils à ma carrière
cinq six mille fille j'ai vu passer
oui l'isf non c'est pas de béring mon
métier j'ai vu passer un millier de
jeunes comédiens qui qui au départ était
inconnu qui entre-temps devenu très
célèbre est atteint ou certaines et puis
bon je suis dans la vie dont ils
s'enquièrent c'est vrai que des fois
quand le titre on arrive plus à éjaculer
au bout de quelques scènes on met du
lait nestlé oui on prend un fait battre
le coeur 9 de la glère des fous du lait
nestlé oui avant qu'elle comprend du
lait puis la fille se met ça dans la
bouche son du moteur
d'accord on ouvre la bouche alors ça
cool et puis ça a d'ailleurs ça c'est
tout un temps de raconter tout ça devant
marcel avait été mitigé elle était avant
alger tient au courant
et ces dix mois alors jean-pierre la
suppression à trahir un secret mais ces
excuses moi mettre ton sexe mesure
combien je ne sais pas trop 25 avait
quand même 35 23
entre les deux entre les deux cette
affaire alors rien la maison maintenant
dernière question qu'on reste très bien
j'aime ma femme on fait l'amour tous les
soirs et elle sait ça et elle c'est sale
et très intelligente et là on fait la
différence entre ma vie professionnelle
immaculé donc dépassé à dire tu tournes
toute la journée le soir tu arrives tu
remets le couvert mais parce que sans
rien voir jeudi ça n'a absolument rien
voir des corrections de ne rien rater de
zinal habitudes abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus